die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend den
sonntagsport im Blick hat heute Norbert
Lehmann für uns ein schön guten Abend
auch von mir dann verschaffen wir uns
jetzt einen
Überblick rüsten für den Protesttag
bundesweit wollen Bauern morgen gegen
die Bundesregierung demonstrieren ihr
Verbandschef will rechte Gruppen
fernhalten die Unterwelt der Hamas mit
israelischen Soldaten ist unser
Korrespondent im Tunnelsystem der Terror
unterwegs und Triumph in Sydney
angeführt von Alexander SEV gewinnt das
deutsche Tennisteam überraschend den
United
Cup für morgen sollten viele auf ihrem
Weg zur Arbeit oder Schule vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr Zeit einplanen
Landwirte starten morgen früh im
gesamten Bundesgebiet ihre Protestwoche
die Bauern planen Kundgebungen aber vor
allem Konvois mit Traktoren dabei wollen
sie schon in den frühen Morgenstunden
unden bundesweit viele
Autobahnauffahrten blockieren außerdem
sollen Innenstädte lahmgelegt werden ihr
Ziel dass die Bundesregierung auch die
Kürzungen beim Agrardiesel komplett
zurücknimmt Christian
Volk für Thomas Kunz ist das Fass schon
seit längerer Zeit übergelaufen er ist
Landwirt in Achter Generation doch sein
Hof in der Nähe von Wiesbaden leide
unter immer mehr Auflagen und immer
weniger Subventionen sagt er deshalb
bereitet sich Kunz auf die Bauer
Proteste vor die Stimmung ist so
Granaten schlecht in der Landwirtschaft
dass ich große Sorgen habe dass die
jungen Menschen sagen wi weißt du was
ich mache das hier einfach nicht weiter
und die Konkurrenzsituation verschärft
sich immer mehr und die Betriebe haben
immer mehr Druck zu wachsen um diesem
kostendrock zu begegnen 100.000 l Diesel
verbraucht der Landwirt pro Jahr die
geplanten Kürzungen der Subventionen in
mehreren Schritten würden kunstjährlich
wohl bis zu 10000 € Kosten der deshalb
will er morgen in Wiesbaden den Verkehr
ausbremsen und nicht nur dort auch in
allen anderen Bundesländern planen die
Bauern etwa große traktorenkonvois und
blockierte
Autobahnauffahrten die werden mit
schweren Traktoren und LKW durch
Deutschland fahren und werden sich an
Recht und Gesetz halten müssen und wenn
sie das nicht tun wird die Polizei auch
Maßnahmen treffen sie wird Festnahmen
auch von traktorfahrern durchführen
können das ist schwierig das ist
gefährlich aber morgen ist klar wer am
Protest teilnimmt muss sich friedlich
verhalten nach der bauernblockade gegen
Wirtschaftsminister habbeck warnen die
Behörden dass Extremisten die Proteste
unterwandern könnten doch der
Bauernverband macht klar persönliche
Angriffe Drohungen etc das ist ein No Go
und wir werden dafür sorgen dass unsere
angemeldeten Demonstrationen friedlich
verlaufen für Landwirt Thomas Kunz ist
der Protest morgen nur ein Anfang für
viele andere in Deutschland gilt sie sie
müssen wohl etwas früher aufstehen um
rechtzeitig zum Termin zur Arbeit oder
in die Schule zu
kommen bei der Klausur der CSU
Landesgruppe im Kloster Seon stand heute
der Kampf gegen Antisemitismus im
Mittelpunkt die Abgeordneten fordern
Antisemitismus als besonders schweren
Fall der Volksverhetzung einzustufen und
entsprechend zu ahnen auf Hetze gegen
Israel müssten mindestens 6 Monate
Freiheitsstrafe Folgen zu Gast war der
Präsident des Zentralrat der Juden in
Deutschland Josef Schuster er erklärte
höhere Strafen könnten abschreckend
wirken im Westjordanland sind bei einem
israelischen Luftangriff sieben Menschen
ums Leben gekommen laut Militär waren es
Terroristen umgekehrt gab es auch
Angriffe durch militante Palästinenser
ein 28-Jähriger wurde in seinem Auto
erschossen und bei einem antiroreinsatz
kam eine israelische Polizistin durch
einen Sprengsatz ums Leben auch im
Gazastreifen halten die
Auseinandersetzungen an Israels Armee
hat nach eigenen Angaben jetzt die
militärische Struktur der Hamas im
Norden des Landstrichs zerschlagen dort
hatte die Terrororganisation vor genau
drei Monaten die Grenze bei eres
überwunden und in Israel Massaker verübt
für den Überfall nutze die Hamas Tunnel
einen 4 km langen Durchgang konnte unser
Reporter Michael bwerunge erkunden
begleitet von israelischen Soldaten
Rückkehr nach eres an einen der
zentralen Orte an dem vor genau dre
Monaten der brutalste Terrorangriff in
der Geschichte Israels begann der
Grenzgang wurde als erstes angegriffen
Kameras und automatische Waffen zerstört
in unmittelbare Nähe zur Grenzmauer
führt die israelische Armee Journalisten
einenonderen Tunnel vor kaum zu glauben
dass es die Hamas geschafft hat diesen
Tunnel unbemerkt bis nur wenige Meter an
die
israelischenenzanlagen heranzutreiben
Abstieg in die Unterwelt der Hamas die
mit größter Präzision und zum Teil
selbstgebauten Tunnelbohrmaschinen
angelegt wurde dieser Tunnel ist 4 km
lang und bis zu 50 m tief hier passt ein
Kleinwagen durch na ja das ist natürlich
ein angriffstunnel weil er wirklich nur
400 m ungefähr von der Grenze zu Israel
aufhört und es hat natürlich nur einen
Sinn dass sie wenn sie angreifen wollen
eventuell diesen Tunnel nutzen obwohl
sie ih am 7 Oktober nicht genutzt haben
in der Kriegsführung der ham spielt das
Tunnelsystem insgesamt eine zentrale
Rolle es kann sein dass sie von dort
ihre Operation ausführen es kann sein
dass sie dort Geiseln gefangen halten
das sind Unterschlupf Orte natürlich das
sind Orte wo sie Raketen von A nach B
schieben wenn Sie wollen und die
Terroristen selbst wenn Sie von A nach B
wollen die Luft ist stickig und feucht
Millionen Kubikmeter Beton die dem
zivilen Aufbau von Gaza gestohlen wurden
viele Tunnel und tunnelausgänge sind
noch gar nicht entdeckt und die Armee
geht davon aus dass sie gar nicht alle
finden wird und auch gar nicht nicht
alle zerstören kann noch sind Anlagen
wie diese die stärkste Waffe der
Hamas zum vierten Mal in drei Monaten
besucht Außenministerin berbock Israel
für eine weitere Vermittlungsmission vor
Beginn mnte sie mehr Rücksicht auf die
Zivilisten im gazerastreifen an in
Jerusalem wurde sie am Abend von ihrem
Kollegen Katz empfangen später kam sie
auch mit Präsident Herzog zusammen Thema
der Gespräche dürften unter anderem
Bemühungen zur Freilassung der von der
Herr ten Geiseln sein morgen will
berbock sich auch mit Palästinensern
Treffen in Russland wird gerade
Weihnachten gefeiert weil sie sich als
orthodoxe Christen nach dem julianischen
Kalender richten Präsident Putin empfing
Angehörige gefallener Soldaten ließ aber
diesmal keine Feuerpause über die
Feiertage ausrufen der Patriarch der
russischorthodoxen Kirche steht voll
hinter seinem Präsidenten Armin Körper
berichtet aus
moskauau ein Wintermärchen trotz
klirrender Kälte zieht es die
Hauptstädter gestern Abend auf die
Straße und in die Kirche es ist das
zweite Weihnachtsfest seit Russland
Krieg führt in der Ukraine die Mehrheit
im Land will Frieden aber nur zu den
Konditionen des Krimmel der Sieg wird
unser Sein wir lieben unsere Heimat und
wir wollen nicht dass Menschen sterben
in der christerlöser Kathedrale feiert
Patriarch Kirill mit vielen Gläubigen
der hat Jahr zu keiner feiertäglichen
Feuerpause aufgerufen so sterben laut
Meldungen in der ebenfalls mehrheitlich
orthodoxen Ukraine am Wochenende
besonders viele
Kinder auch an der Front sprechenend
Vertreter der Kirche den Segen für die
russischen Krieger das Morden geht dann
Weihnachten weiter im Namen
Gottes Präsident Putin zeigt sich mit
den Familien gefallener Soldaten und
spricht seine
Botschaft Mitarbeiter sind immer an
eurer Seite alle Ebenen der Verwaltung s
dass ihr immer wissen sollt es ist
jemand für euch da falls ihr Hilfe
braucht in Moskau und STT petersburg
fordern einzelne Frauen die Heimkehr
ihrer mobilisierten Männer Blumen aus
Protest diese Weihnachtsbotschaft ist
die mutigste in diesem Jahr in
Russland so jetzt geht's mit Norbert
weiter und mit großem deutschen Tennis
heute in Sydney ja kurz vor Beginn der
Australien der Sieg im United Cup in
einem packenden Finale gegen Polen
zunächst hatte im Einzel Angeli Kerber
verloren danach siegte Alexander Sif ja
die Entscheidung fiel dann im mixdoppel
mit Laura
Siegemund und zwar im Match tebreg im
dritten Satz hier trumpfen Laura
Siegemund und Alexander zwerref gegen IG
sonontek und Hubert hurkatsch so richtig
auf mit solchen Punkten zeigen sie ganz
klar dass sie diesen Titel in Australien
unbedingt gewinnen wollen Siegemund mit
Gefühl und ZF dann mit Präzision und
harte 8 Z3 schnell die Führung für das
deutsche Duo Matchball nach knapp einer
Stunde und 45 Minuten Siegemund und
zwerf gewinnen mit 6 Z4 5 Z7 und 10 Z4
und Deutschland damit den United Cup in
Sydney zum biathlonheimcup in Oberhof da
lief es für die deutsche frauenstaffeln
heute nicht so gut nur Platz 5
wesentlich erfolgreicher dagegen die
Männer gefeuert von über 20 000
Zuschauern ging Schlussläufer Philip
Horn ins Rennen und vermiet nach dem
dritten Nachlader eine Strafrunde am
Ende dann Platz 2 hinter Norwegen das
DSV Quartett im dritten Staffelrennen
der Saison mit dem dritten
Podestplatz und ebenfalls ein deutscher
zweiter Platz beim 10 km Massenstart zum
Abschluss der tourdei in Wald fjemme
Langläufer Friedrich moch hinten im Bild
auf der zielgraten ein harter Zweikampf
den der Franzose gewann m wurde damit
Zweiter in der Gesamtwertung und das ist
der erste deutsche Podestplatz seit 15
Jahren ja hat ganz schön lange gedaut
besonderes Danke Schön wir blicken noch
fix aufs Wetter morgen setzt sich im
Nordosten die Sonne durch auch sonst
freundlich nur an den Alpen Schneid noch
leicht bei kaltem Nordostwind gibt -7
bis +
1° so wir haben noch diese Meldung ab
Mittwoch könnte es zu Behinderung im
Bahnverkehr kommen die Gewerkschaft GDL
kündigte am Abend einen dreitägigen
Streik bis Freitag an bauernpräsident
rugwiet ab 21:45 Uhr im heute
journalinterview mit Christian sieas